russia's Foreign Minister is in the
French capital this Tuesday attending
the Paris peace forum it's an event
aimed at promoting better global
governance Sergey Lavrov was drawn on
the subject of global responsibilities
the West is pretty much blame to be
blamed for everything no no not for
everything just for its own mistakes
well very strong speech by the Russian
Foreign Minister outlining his vision of
what's happening in the world at the
moment and talking about some of the
issues with what he sees as the way that
the West has viewed itself in the past
and how it views itself in the presence
in terms of its global domination he
said that the West needs to take
responsibility for its actions it needs
to understand that its domination of
world affairs has been melting away and
it said that it needs to accept that the
world of the future is a plural centric
world in fact they even went as far as
accusing the West of preventing this
from taking place
of course our Western friends are not
happy because for more than five hundred
more than five centuries they dominated
the the political economic and cultural
civilizational life on this planet they
try to put this process this objective
process on brakes well he also was
talking about some of the recent events
over the last few weeks he talked about
the Catalonia he talked about things
that were happening in Bolivia of course
a resignation of another former Bolivian
President Evo Morales and he talked
about the fact that the intervention
there wasn't the pointed finger being
pointed at Russia Russia hasn't been
accused of meddling in any of these
countries but he suggested that
essentially somebody else was somehow we
have not been accused of the coup in
Bolivia and this is strange so something
is happening in the minds of those who
normally create geopolitical agenda I
believe that it is very unfortunate what
we see in in in in
it is very unfortunate to see Lebanon in
this stage of you know distress but
don't forget that in Iraq
the people still try to overcome the
effect of the American American invasion
we also saw a little bit of humor from
the Russian Foreign Minister he was
asked during the question-and-answer
session how was Russia preparing for the
2020 US election we talked a lot about
the u.s. today so I wonder it the
presidential elections are coming up in
2020 so how is Russia are getting ready
for that will resolve the problem don't
worry but the main thoughts of Sergey
Lavrov at the Paris Peace Conference was
the fact that to respond to the global
demands to global conflicts that
countries need to work together and that
means that the way forward is a
polycentric way forward and not the
dominance of the West
you